pour karim pakzad chercheur à l'iris un
aspect de cet accord inquiète la
population locale et les autorités
selon ce spécialiste de l'afghanistan le
texte prévoit notamment de faire des
talibans les alliés des etats unis
il s'en grille qui lie à une annexe dans
la corde qui prévoit qu entre l'état les
banques et les américains à partir de
demain il y aura une coopération sur les
questions de renseignement et dans le
cadre de la lutte antiterroriste
c'est à dire que cet accord prévoit
quelque part comme étant les banques
deviendront à na li et des américains et
de l'autre côté même si demain dans dix
jours les pourparlers internes avant de
recommencer
mais en même temps elle étend le moment
pas relancé à réinstaurer leur propre
pouvoir sous le land de emma rater cela
mit à boston où tout ou soit un autre
nom c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
pense que la question est ouverte qu il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes notamment deux
côtés des argons qui sont en titane est
bonne concernant le sort des acquis de
ces 10 des 18 dernières années sur les
droits de l'homme sur le droit des
femmes sur le travail des femmes sur une
éducation des femmes sont libérées de
presse sur tous ces points là les temps
réponse ils n'ont pas changé ils n'ont
pas changé ils ont la même conception
que il ya 18 ans c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut considérer que
aujourd'hui avec la signature d'un
accord entre états les banques et les
américaines c'est la première pas vers
la paix